being an actor would you you want to add
you know you want you want to be on
stage or whatever you're doing if you're
on camera or film TV you want to be
doing that on London's
billion-dollar-a-year West End pretty
woman was set for a sold-out run with
actor Mark Holden among the cast then
just weeks after opening coronavirus
brought the curtain down in our
profession 90% of actors are out of work
at any one time what are they doing the
rest of the time in normal circumstances
and we're not in normal start to certain
circumstances now we're in something
that our generation is never experienced
it's estimated that without a government
rescue up to 70% of performing arts
companies countrywide will close for
good but the government has not so far
included theater among the businesses
it's trying to protect some larger
theatre companies have already announced
that layoffs are inevitable meanwhile
Andrew Lloyd Webber the creator of
phantom of the opera is trialing thermal
imaging equipment to test audience
temperatures and make it safer to return
eventually they will likely survive many
smaller companies may not and for this
sin there is no remedy the fight back
has been online like the sonnet a day
program performed under the auspices of
the tiny German Street Theatre why did
that promise such a beauteous day but
it's no match for ticket sales we all
need financial help airlines are getting
financial help we need financial help in
the same way that most theaters in fact
I think all theaters must have an
audience to be able to pay their bills
we need help because if we don't have
audience coming into our buildings who
are able to buy those tickets these
buildings won't survive they will
collapse a packed auditorium here is
just 70 people social distancing will
mean future audiences of less than half
that size nowhere near enough to survive
and so to the writers
new work but for fewer actors to keep
costs down
I think writers will have to find
different ways of telling multi-car
stories it will still be the same story
it will still have the same content but
even under that adversity writers will
trust try to find a way or producing the
same story within only a couple of
characters Shakespeare produced plays
like King Lear and Macbeth while in
lockdown because of the bubonic plague
now - there will be cauldrons of
creative work bubbling away behind
closed doors the question is what sort
of theatre world will exist to bring it
all to life jonah hull al jazeera london